the more expensive it is the easier it
is to sell cuz you're dealing with
better people you probably had a
Consulting client that pays you 50 Grand
it's like oh yeah by the way I sent the
wire yesterday whereas the $50 person
like what exactly am I going to be
getting with this program you know what
I mean it's just it's a different person
you know what I mean you're dealing with
a different Avatar and from an actual
selling perspective almost every sale is
the same regardless so you might as well
just do the sales that you're getting
paid $5,000 for rather than sales you're
getting $20 for learn how to sell and
then find the most expensive thing you
possibly can to sell